vedanta is a very significant and
popular school of thought or tradition
within the larger religious tradition of
hinduism or sanatana dharma
outside of the indian context the
advaita school or non-dualistic school
of vedanta is probably the most famous
but as we've seen in previous episodes
this is by no means the whole of the
tradition in another good showcase of
how
diverse religions can be even within
specific schools of thought or
traditions of a religion like hinduism
there can be such differences of opinion
that they can be seen as being the
complete polar opposites of each other
yes we have now reached the third and
final part in our trilogy about the main
schools of vedanta we've gone from the
absolute monism or non-dualism of
shankara to the absolute dualism of
mother
[Music]
the school associated with madhava often
known as mothvacharya the acharya being
an honorific title meaning something
like teacher is usually referred to as
dwight de vedanta which can roughly be
translated as the vedanta of dualism
it heavily challenged the doctrines of
its non-dualistic leaning predecessors
and came to have an enormous impact and
influence on hinduism before we get into
it i think it's good to have a bit of a
recap first as always i of course
recommend that you watch the previous
episodes in this series to get a fuller
grasp of the context in which this
conversation takes place but let's
summarize what we've learned so far
vedanta is essentially a exegetical
scholarly tradition within hinduism
primarily concerned with interpreting
the vedas specifically the upanishads as
well as other texts like the
brahmasutras and the bhagavad-gita and
as this tradition started to grow a
couple of centuries into the common era
various schools and interpretations
arose different scholars who interpreted
these textual sources in different ways
the upanishads and brahma sutras which
is kind of a commentary on the first as
well as the vedantic scholars are
concerned with a few key concepts
there is first the brahman the ultimate
reality the absolute or the one the
source of all things including the
different gods
secondly there is the atman or the self
both in terms of our individual selves
but also in the sense of a pure
transcendent absolute or universal self
the reality of pure subjectivity and
while all the scholars of vedanta dealt
with these themes and concepts they
interpreted them and their relationship
differently the first example of a
systematized school of vedanta is
associated with the figure shankara who
likely lived in the 8th century
his school known as advaita vedanta was
monistic
brahman a reality entirely without
attributes is the only thing that is all
things are in fact brahman forming a
total oneness and all experience or
appearance of multiplicity or of things
including the self being other than the
brahman is the result of avidya
ignorance and maya illusion
the second figure that we have explored
ramanuja didn't like this at all and
spent much of his life refuting shankara
school to him advaitha robbed god or
vishnu of his rightful attributes and
thus neglected rituals and devotional
worship or bhakti
ramanuja whose school is known as
vishista dwight vedanta instead proposed
that brahman is identical to the god
visnu with all of his attributes and
rejected the attributeless brahman of
shankara the human worshipper needs god
to be different from himself in order to
worship him and receive his saving grace
however he still held fast to a
qualified form of monism by stating that
all things are brahman or vishnu but we
are like parts of his body he being the
soul that moves the body so it's both a
kind of non-dualism but one that still
upholds a certain level of difference
between god and human and the importance
of devotion bhakti for reaching
liberation and it is into this debate
that madhva is born and lives his life
he was born in the late 13th century
close to the city of udupi in the modern
state of karnataka in southwestern india
he grows up and lives in an environment
that is incredibly diverse in terms of
religion and intellectual thought
not only were there various schools of
scholarly hinduism like the different
movements of vedanta already mentioned
but also other groups like the shaivites
worshippers of shiva jains the atheistic
chadovakas and many more
even the muslims would have made their
way into the region at this time in
other words this was a pluralistic
environment full of discussion and
debate something that likely influenced
the later career of madhva he was born
into a brahmana or priestly family and
thus early in his life engaged in
studying the vedas and later vedanta
under a teacher that was inclined
specifically to shankara's advaita
interpretation but madhwa eventually
left this master due to heavily
disagreeing with the advaitha
interpretation of the upanishads we see
this happen a few times in his life
madhva studying under a teacher of
vedanta but breaking with him due to
disagreement and instead eventually led
his own path and developed a new school
of interpretation
the events of madhva's life follow a
similar pattern to other hydrographical
accounts of other sages he became a
sannyasin or renunciant ascetic during
his teenage years and was exceptionally
intellectually gifted
after studying and developing his own
philosophy he traveled and debated
scholars from various different schools
of thought and defeated them he's said
to have opened a few mathhas or
monasteries and there formed a community
around him that would grow into great
prominence
madhva much like ramanuja before him was
heavily concerned with refuting the
advaita interpretation of vedanta
instead leading his followers to a pure
devotional worship of vishnu which
according to him was the only way to
liberation he saw himself as having a
great responsibility to lead people to
god through correct interpretation
worship and social order
indeed it appears that madhva actually
saw himself as an avatar or incarnation
of the wind god value who is the son of
visnu thus serving an important role as
an intermediary or guide for the people
to reach god this mission was not only
theological and ontological but also
social indeed atheist scholar deepak
sharma says quote
madhvacharya's theology is thus founded
on the importance of taratamiya
hierarchy as evidenced in the prevailing
systems of varna class and jyati cast
the centrality of social structure for
madvacaria and maintenance of the status
quo may be a reaction to the diversity
and menace of rival gnostica or
non-vedic traditions in medieval
karnataka
any good vedantic scholar madhva wrote a
number of important works the most
important of these is probably
you guessed it a commentary on the
brahma sutra as well as commentaries on
the bhagavad-gita and a various
different upanishads what is interesting
about madhva is that he not only wrote
his great major commentary on the brahma
sutras his great basia but also three
separate commentaries on it which was
quite unusual and he also wrote
independent treatises where he argued
against the schools of shankara's
advaita or ramanuja vishishtadvaita and
presenting his own ideas which would
become known as dwight davidant or
dualistic vedanta so what are these
arguments about and what are the
features of madhva's own thought well as
i said earlier all of vedanta is
essentially occupied with the same
themes but they interpret them and their
relationships in different ways
and we can zoom out and look at the
indigenous religions of india generally
and come to a similar conclusion whether
we are talking about many of the various
hindu traditions or jainism or buddhism
they all have a few things in common
name the ideas about samsara the cycle
of rebirths that all life forms go
through as well as karma the force that
determines the nature of that rebirth
also common to the indic religions is a
common final goal to be released from
the wheel of samsara to end one cycle of
rebirth and reach final liberation which
is known in hinduism as moksha
so it's important to remember when we
talk about these different schools of
vedanta that they are all essentially
concerned with the same goal of reaching
ultimate liberation or moksha and all
the different theological and
ontological practical differences are
simply different ways of finding the
correct or at least most effective way
of reaching that liberation
so for example very famously shankara's
advaita vedanta had proposed that it was
janana yoga or more properly pronounced
gyana yoga which is the yoga of
knowledge that was the prime way to
reach moksha right to know to to reach
knowledge of one's own identity the
self's identity with the brahman
everything is the brahman and to reach
liberation according to shankara and the
non-dualistic school of advaitha is to
realize and come to the
the full knowledge
of one's identity with the one brahman
rituals and deity worship while not
neglected entirely become secondary in
advaita at best they are steps on the
way to the actual solution reaching the
knowledge that there is only one thing
brahman and ourself or atman is
identical to that brahman it is this
concept that people like ramanuja and
especially madhva was completely
appalled by this was the entirely wrong
interpretation according to them
two madhva the and athman are not
identical not at all in fact they are
entirely separated and the only way to
reach moksha is through devoted worship
of god in the form of vishnu like in the
case with ramanuja it's difficult to
talk about madhva and his school of
dwight vedanta without making constant
comparisons to the other schools this is
because madhava's writings and his well
all of his ideas are really in direct
response to those other schools and
because of that they are often best
understood in relation to those other
schools this is the way that we can
understand his ideas better by situating
his ideas within that wider debate and
discussion
the three main schools of vedanta
advaita vishishta dwaita and dwighta can
be seen as existing on a spectrum where
advaita and dwighta are each on opposite
sides of that spectrum
in terms of ontology advaita teaches
that all that is is the attributeless
brahman i am brahman you are the
brahmana the cat is the brahmana this
conversation even is brahman and all our
experience of multiplicity or other than
brahman is only the result of
superimposition or aviasa and ultimately
not real just like we mistake a rope to
be a snake
mothva's ontology is the very opposite
of this the common name of the school
duitta meaning to or duel suggests his
position
the world to madhwa is entirely
dependent on god or vishnu who is
identical to brahman he essentially
divides reality into two fundamental
categories things that are dependent and
things that are independent
the only thing that is independent is
vishnu and everything else is dependent
on him sustained by him and created by
him quote the lord vishnu is the only
independent thing
this god is not the attributeless
brahman of advaita vedanta it is saguna
brahman brahman with attributes entirely
vishnu is a personal god with exalted
attributes fitting of a god not some
impersonal abstract reality
thus in duitta vedanta brahman is not
the reality of all things like in
writers like shankara brahman in the
form of vishnu with attributes is a god
that is different from ourselves and the
created world
so we have reached the entirely other
side of the spectrum by this point
rather than being the ultimate reality
and true essence of all things brahman
or vishnu is here transcendent and a
force outside of ourselves to which we
must turn in worship quote as stated in
the paramasruti the wise recognize that
the universe is known and protected by
vishnu therefore it or the universe is
proclaimed to be real but hadi alone is
supreme
this brings madhav a lot closer to what
many would consider a classical
monotheism but his theology is also
quite different in some ways from
religions like christianity
to mother god is the efficient or
instrumental cause of all things but not
their material cause
this is philosophical jargon to say that
vishnu did not create the world ex
nihilo or from nothing he didn't create
the matter and stuff which makes up
everything rather the material stuff
known as pradakriti has always existed
as such and vishnu only forms this
matter and causes this matter to become
specific things this is a little more
similar to the demiurge or craftsmen in
plato's timaeus
additionally there are other principles
that are also eternal aside from god
such as time or kala but his main point
still stands vishnu is the supreme lord
who is the only independent reality and
all other dependent reality is dependent
on him thus different from him and as he
alluded to in the quote before it is
ultimately real the world around us is
entirely real to madhva it is not maya
or illusion based on ignorance or
superimposition but a true reality that
can be known directly through perception
this can be seen especially in madhva's
epistemology or theory of knowledge
the vedantans and all other schools of
hindu thoughts are heavily concerned
with what is known as the pramanas the
means of true knowledge but they
disagreed on what it constituted
what is it that can give us true
knowledge of the world as it is or
especially of the brahman and the atma
as we saw in the episode on shankara and
advaita he believed that the only true
pramana or means of knowledge when it
comes to the ibrahman was scripture in
other words the vedas on upanishads
because our common view of the world is
essentially based on ignorance and
misunderstanding we cannot trust our
senses or deductions to tell us anything
about the ultimately real instead we
must rely on revealed and inspired
scripture to guide us
but madhva is significantly more
inclusive when it comes to what counts
as a pramana to madhva there are
primarily a few different means of
knowledge or pramanas kevala
which is direct knowledge of an object
as it is and then there is ano pramana
which is indirect knowledge and the
instruments with which direct knowledge
is reached and these instruments are
divided into three main categories
firstly there is pratyaksha which is
essentially sense perception
all of our senses including the thinking
mind experiences real objects in the
world outside ourselves and can deduce
truth claims about them the self or soul
of the individual known as both atman
and as the jiva are entirely separated
from brahman ontologically but they
still have a connection
to madhva the soul is like a mirror
image of the brahman or vishnu so it
contains indirect traces of god but in a
more real sense they are of course not
the same thing other than platyaksha or
perception the pramanas include anumana
or defect-less inference in other words
of making logical deductions based on
one's perception like claiming that
where there is smoke there is fire for
example very famous example from indian
philosophy and lastly there is agama or
scripture
scripture is a central means of
knowledge to madhava just as it was for
shankara both the shruti or reveal text
like the vedas but also smirthi or human
written but divinely inspired texts like
the puranas mahabharata bhagavad-gita
and the brahma-sutras
but as you can see madhwa includes many
other pramanas as well and he seems to
actually prioritize pratyaksha or
perception as the most important
followed by scripture which really shows
you how much of a realist he was
you can have direct true knowledge of
reality by simply experiencing it as it
is there is no illusion or
superimposition involved here
but things are of course a lot more
complicated than this as well
mothvacharya's ontology and epistemology
are very hierarchical and every
branch or category also has a number of
sub-branches and it just goes on like
that for a long time we're not going to
get into the complexities of mothva's
many different categories and
hierarchies today instead focusing on
his main arguments and the general
statements that he makes but if you're
interested in studying this deeper then
check out the literature or sources in
the description of this episode so we've
already established how madhva differs
from other thinkers like shankara in
some very fundamental ways
god or brahman is full of infinite
attributes
he is a personal god who is different
from the world and sustains the world
the world itself is not maya or illusion
it is absolutely real and can be known
directly through things like sense
perception
thus even though madhwa and shankara are
reading the exact same sources like the
upanishads and the brahmasutras they are
coming to very very different
conclusions
and all this comes from mothva's
essential focus on worship and devotion
known as bhakti
just like ramanuja before him madhva
belonged to the vaishnavite tradition of
devotional worship to the god vishnu in
particular as well as his avatars and
incarnations like krishna and rama
shankara and the advaitans don't belong
to this tradition in the same way which
is what allows them to put a lower
emphasis on devotion
but as a vaisnavait madhava cannot
accept this position
all these ideas that he has is aimed at
the ultimate goal to allow the person to
have a proper view of the world of god
and their relationship to each other so
that he can respond properly to his
position in that reality and reach
moksha or liberation
but what is that response and what is
the role of the human being
well in a way we've already answered
that question the role of the human
being in this whole scheme is to devote
his or herself to vishnu and worship him
quote bhakti devotion comes from
knowledge of the greatness of god and is
the strongest in all circumstances when
compared to others
moksha is achieved by this and in no
other manner
just like basically all other thinkers
in hinduism mother is primarily
concerned with reaching liberation or
moksha to be freed from these cycle of
rebirths or samsara and as we saw
earlier different schools of vedanta
interpreted how this goal is achieved in
different ways so shankara's advaita
vedanta said that it is gyana yoga the
yoga of knowledge of knowing one's own
identity with the brahman and the
brahmanas all encompassing nature as the
only reality that exists but madhva as
we've seen was quite clear on the matter
that it is only bhakti yoga or the yoga
of devotion that ultimately leads to
liberation
he doesn't say that bhakti is the only
important thing though the other yogas
like karma yoga and gyana yoga are still
important steps on the way what begins
with karma yoga the yoga of actions and
rituals gyana yoga that of knowledge is
a required step to reach true devotion
one must have proper knowledge about the
nature of god and the self and the
relationship as being separate for
example to be able to properly devote
oneself to worship but at the end of the
day these are only prerequisites that
lead to the end goal and the only true
way of being liberated which is bhakti
bhakti is devoted worship of god in this
case vishnu in pure love and adoration
praying to god making offerings all the
things that come with devotional
practice that is the only way to
liberation
and even then it's not like the human
being has control over when moksha
arrives it isn't the case where one is
devoted enough to god that there's some
kind of point one reaches when there is
sudden liberation instead all the
devotional practices only prepare the
practitioner to receive the grace or
prasada of vishnu it is ultimately god
who decides when the person reaches
liberation further emphasizing the
ultimate power of god over all things
once this has been reached the jiva can
leave a blissful existence without
rebirth in a heavenly world that in
itself has various different grades and
stations in relation to closeness to
vishnu
perhaps it is here that the great
teacher madhva himself resides
not only did he of course reach moksha
according to dwight the tradition but as
we saw earlier he was also considered
the very avatar of the god value indeed
according to the hagiographies madhva
never actually died but it is said that
he simply disappeared one day vanished
to never be seen again a fitting end
perhaps to a figure that is as
mysterious and charismatic as he was
mad was interpretation of vedanta which
became known primarily as dwight vedanta
became a significant intellectual force
in hinduism his huge focus on devotional
worship of a personal god that stood
above creation was very attractive to a
lot of people and he managed to
challenge the great schools of previous
figures like shankara and ramanuja
originally madhvas vedanta was
pretty confined to the region where he
lived and was born in karnataka but
eventually it also spread all across
india and today has also spread really
all across the world and has influenced
various different movements even
contemporary ones like the hare krishna
movement he and ramanuras
have tended to appeal more to the
general masses and hindu practitioners
due to their interpretation of a
personal god who can be worshipped much
more so than the heavy and scholarly
thought of shankara but all of these
schools as well as various other ones
that we haven't talked about in this
series make up the diverse tapestry that
is vedanta and hinduism through these
episodes we have seen how varied ideas
can be even within the same
philosophical tradition and that it is
useless to make the kind of
generalizations that many people tend to
make when talking about a religion like
hinduism or sanatana dharma even though
this was the last episode in this
trilogy there is a lot more to explore
of course and we will continue to dive
deeper into the many
fascinating religious traditions and
intellectual currents in india in future
episodes
i'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign